KUMAIL NANJIANI
To help you get a better sense of
our characters in
Marvel Studios' Eternals,
BARRY KEOGHAN
We're going to play a little game called...
GEMMA CHAN
Choose Your Eternal.
LAUREN RIDLOFF [in sign language]
I'm so excited.
KUMAIL NANJIANI
Ha, I'm still gonna win.
BRIAN TYREE HENRY
There are no winners in
Choose Your Eternal,
what are you talking about?
ANGELINE JOLIE
Well...
SALMA HAYEK
Sersi.
DON LEE
Thena.
GEMMA CHAN
Druig.
BRIAN TYREE HENRY
Druig, because he's moping all the time.
ANGELINA JOLIE
Gilgamesh.
LAUREN RIDLOFF [in sign language]
Phastos.
BRIAN TYREE HENRY
Sprite, because she doesn't take
anything seriously.
GILGAMESH
Oh, I'm a big baby.
KINGO
[Laughing]
GEMMA CHAN
Not Sersi.
SERSI
What did I miss?
LIA MCHUGH
Is that even a question? Makkari.
BRIAN TYREE HENRY
Makkari, because she bends time.
KUMAIL NANJIANI
Phastos.
DON LEE
Kingo.
LIA MCHUGH
Uh, me.
SALMA HAYEK
Ajak.
DON LEE
KUMAIL NANJIANI
Ajak.
BRIAN TYREE HENRY
She's not to be overlooked
when it comes to the boogie.
BARRY KEOGHAN
Kingo.
DON LEE
GEMMA CHAN
Gilgamesh?
KINGO
Cut!
Why don't you think about it
and we'll get back to you.
BARRY KEOGHAN
Druig.
SALMA HAYEK
Ajak.
BRIAN TYREE HENRY
Phastos.
ANGELINA JOLIE
I'd like to think Thena.
IKARIS
I can lead them.
[Laughing]